welcome to this video kickoff of new
series one of those new series with
instructional content here on the
channel
this series is about middle games middle
game strategy middle game planning oh
yeah how do you improve your pure middle
game abilities there is some mostly one
way to study games look at games typical
ideas that have been played before and
just try to incorporate them in your own
games very often those things some are
done subconsciously you have seen some
Madea
not really you actively reduce
registered in your brain but still you
somehow remembered and then in a game
you are able to do something identical
or very similar it's really about
looking at games where yeah sort of yeah
in in a model way um this kind of
planning and strategic ideas were
presented and step-by-step you gain more
knowledge and term and and ideas in the
structures that you know it's servant
often helpful to look at structures pawn
structures that come up in your games so
it's a bit difficult for me to select
structures that might appear in your
specific case so it's pretty much that I
try to look at all kinds of structures
the planning very much depends on the
pawn structure of course this is the key
to strategic chess adjust the pieces and
plans according to the to the pawn
structure let's start with this example
it's a game from 1963 Boris Spassky
playing URI Arabic Spassky of course
later become world champion 1969 but he
was one of the strongest players at the
time already I have a buck a very strong
grin
at the time and he's nowadays as the
oldest living Grandmaster being older
with older than 90 I believe let's start
this game we have a little pest and it
really starts around remove 20 where we
where we look at it more deeply but I
just want to show how it how it appeared
this position so we have the absolute
main line of the room and our back plays
the current variation many possible
lines I play Queen c7 here but he went
Knight d7 also moves into the same the
so called Cara's variation Knight bTW -
and now he took here nowadays it is
mostly played in that fashion leading to
a more yeah more confrontational game
this kind of structure is happening
often okay it takes takes and takes on
deform yeah this is not a decision to be
taken lightly the double capture in the
rule of pest this general pawn structure
is appearing quite often it's very often
the case that piece activity compensates
for the worst structure however in this
specific case yeah I think the piece
activity that black has is is not
sufficient I think this line is not very
not very promising for for black but
okay we're not looking at the opening
but how it is unfolding afterwards
yeah our button played Bishop to f6
Sabarsky traded here and now went Bishop
g5 yeah he wants to get rid of this
bishop on f6 that always keeps them the
d4 pawn protected our but not played
Queen to d8 and
masky now traded on f6 so the really
instructional part of this game it's
starting around here it is clear that
white will get the D pawn back at the d4
pawn back and at the end black will
still be settled with this somewhat weak
d6 pawn this is the main main point of
this position or the main feature of
this position that this pawn might be
weak one problem is that black has some
pieces traded already so any possible
counter play that he has especially
against the force is less effective
first point is how should one take at
first you think okay well maybe just
take with the Queen to get more pieces
traded in the endgame the pawn weakness
should be felt the problem is however
technically this is not a good move
because ninety five is stronger that's
very important to notice now White has a
big problem there's the threat of Knight
xf3 was check losing the Queen and the
white really has no good answer to this
something like this is some cat is
really not great at the end age
three-fourths so you must play a very
ugly looking move like ninety two or
even trade and after that black has no
problems whatsoever note that the d6
pawn is now shifted to e5 and here he
has no weak pawn anymore in fact here it
is totally equal maybe we should be
three and we train even more
Queen d4 is a big mistake shouldn't be
played saw Spassky went nine takes
Knight e5 was no played we are
centralizing this night looks a very
like a very logical move black also
could have tried Knight c5 this comes
into consideration trying to make a
little bit more pressure on the only
four white probably should just play a
simple strengthening move like rook see
one
he went to ePHI for about keeping also
this idea in mind and in fact this is
something that white should them should
attend to the night to see for would be
an annoying piece so he went Bishop III
which is a good move anyway as the
bishop is simply better on b3 on this
diagonal then on c2 so we see that white
is improving the pieces slowly Bishop d7
was now played you know this is a slight
sign that black is just somewhat that
something is not quite in order here for
black you really wanted to play Bishop
d7 but he certainly was afraid of a
possible Knight a5 idea here in fact
Bishop takes e4 possible technically
speaking but in general this is
certainly the objection that Arabic had
to this move that sometimes there is a
knight f5 coming also a form is an
interesting move here trying to provoke
more weaknesses him this is a move that
Bishop d7 boss was working against okay
Bishop d7 and here we come to the first
interesting situation Spassky now played
the move rook to c1 which looks like it
a let's say the the the instant move the
move you want to play when you look at
the position at first it might be that
the move Queen d2 was even a bit more
precise that ideas that after Queen d2
mc8 you want to go room 81 yeah using
this rook on the D file we see that this
setup probably saves wide a tempo and
makes the defense a little bit more
difficult for black we see why Luke c1
is played rook a c8 22 everything's
looking very normal and here black
commits I think slight mistake
he plays now Knight to g6 yeah his ideas
possibly to to activate the knight here
but this move on is um yeah he let some
little chance little opportunity slip
black definitely should try to yeah
lessen the pressure but by training you
should trade here and play rook c8
trying to exchange on Brooks when all
rook saturated the whole situation
becomes her lesser problematic for black
as looks other pieces that are mostly
putting pressure on those kind of pawns
yeah the bishop won't be three it's not
a problem in regards to the pawn on d6
it's on a light square and the knight
can also not attack it easily so you
want to trade rooks in this position and
here at least one pair of rooks could
have been traded why probably should
continue with rudy' one keeping at least
one pair on the board this is what black
should have done he however played as
mentioned he played the move Knight g6
and now it's a very instructive
situation here Spassky realized that
putting the rook on c1 was some yeah
maybe an obvious move but not really
helping much he went through see to d1
keeping as many pieces on the board as
possible this very often ISM is a good
strategy if you have pressure on the
opponent's position and he has
difficulty in organizing as forces very
often it's a good idea not to exchange
too much of course all of those rules
they need to apply to concrete positions
and sometimes if you can trade something
and then you win immediately you should
do it but very often it's a good idea to
look at moves that keep the pressure and
not not tray too much yeah here black I
think went for for a plan that is not
very successful but the defense is not
easy maybe you should have played a move
like Rudy
roogie ed he went 95 back
this looks strange but there is a
something has changed in the position
and this is the Lucas of the CFR Black's
idea is to get in the night to see for
this Sun was the plan white however does
not mind that very much he continues
with the very active and aggressive
youth F for the text of the night and
now yeah where should it go
night C form was the plan and was played
in the game still we need to need to
look what else is there yeah black also
could go to g6 or c6 after 96 we
probably just dropped back to e - yeah
keeping f4 protected and now attacking
this pawn right right up front it is a
very nice position black can play Bishop
c6 but then we have a very nice a choice
you can take d6 or we can take f5 first
both leads to lead to a good position
for white yes something like this yeah
and if black now tries to grab we use
this unlucky situation on the on the
e-file night g6 it's not helping very
much in knight c6 is some answer prime
Knight f3 or you can take I think it's
both good you can also take the the
problem is that if you look at rook
takes there's a 5 yeah white is just
better centralized and here it's yeah
you can take d6
or you can play a 5v5 is also very
strong oh I'm sorry this was a more slip
oops this is of course the one I wanted
to play and here White has a fantastic
position the Epona says is very very
strong intending queen here and yeah
like is in big trouble
he went to c4 which was the idea after
all
okay white cannot tolerate this night
and he just took it and now yeah this is
this is now an interesting moment black
took with the pawn I think but hard to
tell I think I still prefer rook takes
but it's not they're not a great
position as well black is just suffering
you on the default with the pawn and
this unlucky position of the bishop we
can't look at rook takes it looks am a
bit better from a structural point of
view than context but it has a concrete
problem of course the problem is that
after b3 rooks e7m to keep this
protected there is 9 f3 we threatened to
just grab the pawn and after move like a
group c6 we play e5 and still win the
pawn so the pressure is just too much on
the on the d6 pawn but maybe like yeah I
don't know maybe is so should have done
that I mean the position after B takes
is it's also it's also not very
attractive but has absolutely a very
little counter play you hard to tell
rook takes is also very very ugly that's
not even a good way to just maybe it's
there some way let me look at this I
didn't look at this so much beforehand
maybe there is a way to jettison the
pawn and some somehow fight I just give
up the pawn for for for for nothing but
but activate pieces it looks it looks
hard to do
White is totally dominating after the
capture maybe a move like d5
hoping for me for this but Dwight will
take with the pawn and play or play
Knight to e5 yeah it's it's a it's not a
nice choice B takes was played and here
we come to the next very instructive
position of this game what white now
needs to do in this position he needs to
find a good setup for his pieces
it's not about calculating a super deep
line hero or be very precise with with
an attack what you need to do is you
need to figure out where the pieces
really belong in this position and
Spassky plays it in a very very nice and
instructive manner he finds the absolute
best setup now Knight to e2 this is the
first very important it shows that the
Knights were looking nice andhe form is
some also presenting a problem for white
with the knight on d4 the pressure on
the D file is blocked the pawn on d6 is
the weakness and we have two pieces
looking at it Queen and rook but with
the knight on the form
yeah well you're never going to take the
pawn it's just it just just blocked by
the by the night and with 92 is
repositioning this Knight to a very good
square and this is to c3 from t3 the
knight has a multi-purpose role it looks
at d5 very nice square it protects a
form which can be a weakness after black
plays Bishop c6 rupee eight moves like
that and the knight is also on a very
safe square on c3 this is very important
Knights absolutely love to be on squares
where they are protected the pawn on be
to always reliably protects the knight
so this is sort of a dream position for
this piece our black plays Bishop a4
yeah try to at least them gain a little
bit
by pushing the rope to see one rupee t8
and 93 and back to c6 of course he must
cover the d5 square you cannot allow 95
yeah and now we see the next step Ruki
one back and h-60 a black basically
needs to sit and wait he's really
suffering from a bad bone structure
white has to pawn islands very typical
thing one pawn island and the second
pawn island those connected pawns you
call porn islands and if you want to
determine who has the better pawn
structure the one who has got fewer pawn
islands is usually the site with the
better structure and here we see that
black in comparison look at this one
point island 2 and 3 black has at least
3 and you could argue that he maybe has
4 as the D pawn on d6 and the policy for
are not protecting each other they are
not really a good good porn island um
yeah but however how are we going to
continue what is the best set of him yes
pass scheme finds the best setup
he plays Queen to e3 what is the point
of this move by the way Queen f2 was
also good what's the point of this move
you want to double on the D file of
course yeah increase the pressure on the
default rook b8 rookie two very
important one rook will be on the second
rank to cover the weakness on b2 and the
other rook will help to pressurize the
point this is the ideal setup one rook
on the two always keeping an eye on this
pawn well there is no counter play now
but you you rather have it protected
it's better this Luke is on d4 the best
possible square at the tech c4 it it
takes d6 it covers you form this is an
ideal setup for white and from here we
can start to figure out how to further
increase the pressure black plate
Queeny seven now he really does not have
any of any active possibility can never
move his deep on or change the pawn
structure in any way the question is
however how do we continue we have a big
pressure on these six and really would
like to win the pawn but how are we
going to manage this now at the moment
we attack it twice it's twice defended
but this is not a situation of a
standstill white can still improve the
situation for him however how to do that
yeah if we look at this the rooks attack
d6
what we want is we want an additional
attacker and this attacker is probably
going to be the queen it's hard to
imagine how the knight would be able to
attack the pawn yeah and the knight is
very well positioned on c3 it does a
good job there how do we use the Queen
to attack the pawn
yeah here there are basically two
possibilities as Queens can move on
diagonals and land on files and ranks it
must be either on the D file or on some
diagonal like this or this yeah there is
simply no other possibility to attack
the pawn it's a bit difficult to imagine
the Queen coming to a3 yeah this looks
looks difficult to achieve and if we go
to a3 we also in a way we can the create
the the King side a bit f4 is a slightly
weak pawn
note that in this specific situation
white would pretty much prefer to have
the F pawn on f3 this would even be a
better pawn structure than having the
pawn on f4 as efore then would be very
securely protected and the whole
situation would even be more stable okay
but not let's not lose the threat to a3
is difficult so where else we can go
maybe 2g 3G three moves the F pawn
attack it on the six this is an idea the
next idea would be on the default so we
could set up something like this Queen
e1
or e2 d1 this typical configuration on
the default rippling with the Queen
behind the rocks this is a very
well-known motif called an occurrence
gun or Loggins gun he had to hit this in
a game famous game against the
nimzowitsch Sanremo 1935 I believe if
I'm not mistaken somewhere around that
time
and this was also an idea here but again
the Queen on d1 is a little bit
neglecting the protection of the king
side so Spassky went for the queen g3
idea here we go it's all very logical
and you think of it you want another
attacker and the queen is the attacker
queen g3 King f8 black you really can
only sit and wait f5 and here it is
d6 now is impossible to hold
he tried this man if we look at this
this was a way to protect it for the
moment but after u5 black is collapsing
using the opinio the pawn cannot move
yeah he went through p8 and white now
just took the pawn yeah we're the
British still over bombing position
White has all the activity has not given
given up any any sort of so made any
concession for this for this pawn grab
umm yeah here black played Queen to e5
he could have considered to take only
for him but after this move and Ruby to
White has a fantastic attack will be
very difficult I mean also this is a
very very bad pin so not something that
black can save he played queenie 5 after
which white now just traded and went
whoop d4 yeah all pieces are actively
placed the ruckus in d6 possibly
shifting over here
on the 7th and the rukon deform now it's
doing two things protecting and
attacking at the same time this is the
way it should be you shouldn't have
pieces that are only defending in the
ideal state of your position
a5 yeah not not very helpful
a5 is also weaker but it's a it's very
hard to give black any advice 'i'm white
is now keeping all his positive sights
in the position and activates as much as
possible
rook to a6 and now getting the king also
in the game yeah the king should help
White has time the King now is an
additional protecting piece and it might
also be helpful with further pushes on
the King side note that our advantage
from a structure point of view is on the
Queen side but we can also gain on the
King side gain space this will happen
later rook c5 route d7 why not
the seventh rank is nice to have and
keen to d4 yeah he just keeps all the
activity man
note that this year it was possible but
not the most precise way to play and
something like this is is to be avoided
it loses control of the position white
still is in good shape but why allow
black any counter play against the King
we should just keep the structure as it
is and continue to improve the position
King before Bishop e8 here there was a
possibility to take it for a little bit
more attractive than before but still
might take we have perfect control and
all our pieces are more active it's just
a very important principle that we don't
want to exchange an excellent piece on
c3 against the terrible piece on the 8th
even if we see that it probably wins
it should be not taken lightly somewhere
out here
Black has he's still struggling here and
we have traded for a very weak pawn I
mean the pollen a forest only week
anyway
we have traded our fantastic night
against this ugly Bishop this is not a
good idea
just keep all that Vantage's intact and
here he's trying to double on the
seventh this is just much stronger yeah
G for gain space and now double on the
seventh perfect control black cannot do
anything here when truck c6 and 95 yeah
now we even get to occupy the square
root the eight ng five everything should
be activated as much as possible rope to
d6 yeah how do we finish this off iam
the key point will be certainly the
seventh rank and those pawns but here we
without any problems can also snatch the
pawn black now has no counter play the
bishop only eight is tied to the f7 pawn
and this means that this night would
stay dominant in the center check-check
was given and Roxy to King five whoops
e4 black really cannot do much yeah now
widest is calculating a forced win we as
white iam have many many good moves
certainly I mean something like let's
say something like this is just keeping
everything in good order and will win
but here white has a direct win and spa
scheme of course wanted to win as
quickly as possible he played g6 this is
the the strongest way to finish things
off if black takes root g7 will be
decisive the ideas look age 7 to h8
nothing that black can do he went f6
this is the relatively best best move
but now white can decide matters by of
the P sacrif
Knight takes f6 Jetix king cakes and
here this is just too much the
combination of those pawns and the rooks
on the seventh rank will absolutely kill
black he gave this check check King g5
and here like resigned right after 40 I
move 56 I'm sorry I have a different
County in my notes he resigned now yeah
white is now winning on the on the
seventh rank yeah what should black play
let's just briefly look how it would
have would have went yeah let's say like
this yeah then the easiest way to do it
is to play rook e8 intending rook f7 and
rooks takes 8 and and over you can give
a check here and try to try to hang on
but at the end there's also the G phone
that will prove to be decisive this is a
very nice example for strategic planning
and finding a good setup let's look at
key points one key point here was that
white avoided the rook trade yeah
keeping as many books and many pieces on
the board as possible especially those
that can attack the weakness very
important was this situation here white
needed to find a good setup for the
night and his rooks and he found the
absolute best one the Knight to c3 and
now this this is the best possible
configuration it keeps everything under
control
and it shows that the knight wants to be
on a protected square this is a really
the best square that the knight can mmm
is really better to be on there than on
d2 as the knight on d4 would block the
pressure on the d6 pawn the knight on c3
also reliably protects even though
there's no counter play against this
pawn these are the kind of examples that
one should look at
and I will present more and more of them
in this in this series in order to
improve middlegame ideas and sort of
yeah get to get to the right mindset how
to approach those positions very
difficult that to think in in terms of
schemes and setups and not so much in
terms of concrete moves and and at
variations here it was essential for
Spassky to determine that this thus
queen G 326 for example was a good way
to continue yeah I hope you enjoyed this
first part of the series going to
present much more that was instructed
with dem pots
yeah make sure to stay tuned when they
come thanks for watching